Welcome back to the David Pakman show. I am
Benjamin Dixon filling in for David. While
he is away on vacation, I want to share an
image on your screen. Take a look at this.
This is an image, a graph that was made by,
um, the Washington examiner, which is a right
wing rag. Uh, but they're citing data from
a new Gallup poll that just came out, uh,
that states that fit through only 51% of Americans
think that socialism would be bad for the
u s while 43% think that socialism would be
good for the u s and 6% have no opinion. Now,
uh, if you look in the bottom corner, you
can see they put up the data from 1942 because
they want to scare you. They want you to see
that America is going in their own direction.
Uh, in 1942, uh, 40% thought that socialism
would be bad for the United States, and only
25%, uh, thought that it would be positive
while 34% had no opinion on the matter.
Um, the question that the Gallup poll interviewers
asked was weird. Some form of socialism be
a good thing or a bad thing for the, uh, as
a whole. This, you know, socialism is, is
the Boogeyman, um, the boogeyman of the right.
It has been for some time. And of course,
we can parse the difference between socialism,
communism, particularly Democratic Socialism.
Uh, our, our social worker or a social democracy
versus communism. Um, but this has been the,
the, the Muse of conservatives for time in
Memoriam. Um, they have engaged in the red
scare and I want to be sure about something.
The picture that they, if you don't mind,
uh, pat put in the picture back on the screen.
They have this scary picture of Bernie Sanders
or Bernie Sanders Looking, um, you know, weird
for lack of a better word. And then they have
a AOC laughing. Um, I want to reassure the
American people of something, or at least
those of you who are listening to this program,
Bernie Sanders and Alexandria Ocozzio Cortez,
they are not real socialist.
And I know we can get into that can fall into
the like the no true Scotsman kind of fallacy.
But I want to assure you there are people
way further to the left of Bernie Sanders
and Alexandria Kazuyo Cortez. Hell, I'm to
the left of Bernie Sanders and Alexander,
you're causing Cortez. And I have friends
who scare me with how far left they are. And
then there are people even further to the
left of them. And we're talking about a very
small minority light, like a very small group
of people who are true Communist, you know,
seize the means of production. Communist Bernie
Sanders and Alexandria Ocozzio Cortez are
not that in any way imaginable. I described
Bernie Sanders Socialism as post office socialism,
right? It's and knock Ewas as the post office
are our fire, uh, fire department socialism
it since, since, uh, simply gathering taxes
and doing a social good with them.
Who? Socialism. And so, you know, I put all
of that in context because I want you to understand
the game that is constantly being played on
Americans, Republicans and conservatives in
particular like to play this game that anything,
anything whatsoever that does not capitulate
to the free markets. By the way, the never,
they are not free markets, but that's what
they like to say. So we'll use their terminology
just because anything that does not capitulate
to what Republicans call the free market is
socialism to them. The post office should
be privatized, write to them. Every aspect
of our lives should be privatized. The policing
agencies should be privatized, right? And
they already have private prisons, right?
For profit, right? They believe that the fire
department should be privatized. Our roads
and our infrastructure should be privatized.
So what they're looking for is some extreme
version of laissez faire capitalism that that
really is, that takes all of the government
resources.
What my friend Randy Rhoads always said, our,
our, I believe she coined to first, right,
you a privatized the profits and socialize
the losses. They want to take taxes from the
government and use that to create this, this
utopia of free markets and then turn around
if they lose anything, get that loss, socialized
like the bailout. So they are, they are for
socialism there just for socialism, for the
rich. I believe Bernie Sanders, uh, said that
phrase most popularly, uh, and most recently.
But we're not talking about real socialism.
We're not talking about communism. We're talking
about taking taxes and building a better infrastructure.
We're talking about taking taxes and ensuring
that people have the opportunity to work.
We're talking about taking taxes and t, uh,
making sure that everyone has an opportunity
to go to college without getting in some type
of obscene dead. We're talking about taking
taxes and making sure that our healthcare
industry does not break the backs of people
who get sick.
And not only do you have to compound the fact
that you're sick, but now you're going bankrupt.
That is not this terrifying form of socialism
that is post office bland milk toast, really
easy to palate. It's FDR style socialism.
It is FDR style. Uh, it is, it is yet another
way to be quite honest with you to put a bandaid
on capitalism. So in a lot of ways conservatives
should be embracing Bernie Sanders and Alexandra
Cortez, a Kazuo Cortez because their version
of socialism is really what's going to save
capitalism from itself. And if they are afraid
of Bernie Sanders and, uh, AOC, then whew,
I've got some friends to introduce you to
that it really scare you.